>>> NASA IS STRONGLY CRITICIZING
CHINA FOR ALLOWING ITS BIGGEST
ROCKET TO SHOWER DEBRIS BACK ON
EARTH.
OVER THE WEEKEND WRECKAGE
CRASHED INTO THE INDIAN OCEAN.
IN A STATEMENT, NASA SAID,
QUOTE, IT IS CLEAR THAT CHINA IS
FAILING TO MEET RESPONSIBLE
STANDARDS REGARDING THEIR SPACE
DEBRIS.
RAMY INOCENCIO REPORTS NOW ON
WHY AT LEAST ONE U.S. SCIENTIST
CALLS CHINA'S ACTIONS RECKLESS.
>> Reporter: FROM THESE FIRST
IMAGES OF CHINA'S LONG MARCH 5B
ROCKET BLASTING OFF APRIL 29th,
TO PROUD CHEERS TO THESE LAST
BLURRY IMAGES OF IT FALLING OUT
OF CONTROL BACK TO EARTH OVER
THE ARABIAN PENINSULA SATURDAY.
CRITICISM IS NOW CRASHING DOWN
ON CHINA AFTER ROCKET FRAGMENTS
RAINED DOWN NEAR THE TROPICAL
ISLANDS OF THE MALDIVES.
>> IT'S AN ALARMING THING FOR
THEM TO BE DOING.
>> Reporter: HARVARD SMITHSONIAN
ASTROPHYSICIST JONATHAN McDOWELL
SAYS CHINA'S ROCKET HAS A DESIGN
PROBLEM.
>> WE NORMALLY MAKE SURE THEY
DON'T GO INTO ORBIT AT ALL OR IF
THEY DO THEY HAVE A RESTARTABLE
ENGINE WHICH CAN BRING THEM DOWN
IN A CONTROLLED PLACE.
>> Reporter: LET'S BE CLEAR.
IT'S NOT THAT CHINA CAN'T,
RIGHT?
IT'S THAT THEY DON'T?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Reporter: WAS IT PRICE?
WAS IT LAZINESS?
>> I WOULD THINK IT WAS LACK OF
CONCERN.
>> Reporter: AFTER THE ROCKET'S
RE-ENTRY, NASA ADMINISTRATORS
CALLED ON SPACE NATIONS TO
MINIMIZE RISKS AND MAXIMUM
TRANSPARENCY.
BUT CHINA PLAYED DOWN CONCERN
FROM THE START.
BEIJING DOES NOT TAKE CRITICISM
EASILY OF ANYTHING IT DOES.
HOW WOULD YOU APPROACH THEM TO
SAY, GUYS, LISTEN, WE NEED TO
CHANGE THIS?
>> IF THE U.S. COMES -- THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO TAKE THAT WELL.
THE BEST WE CAN PROBABLY DO IS
HAVE SOME SORT OF INTERNATIONAL
COMMITTEE THAT COMES UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE NOT
COMING FROM ONE COUNTRY, SO IT'S
NOT POLITICALLY